[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir a tous une épreuve de vérité
d'entre deux tours de la campagne
présidentielle bien évidemment avec deux
invités qui vont se succéder sur ce
plateau ce soir d'abord jean paul
delevoye qui est le président de la
commission d'investiture dans marche
c'est lui qui est en train de dresser la
liste des 577 candidats qui se
présenteront aux législatives
ensuite pour marine le pen c'est louis
aliot le vice président du fn et qui
sera ici sur ce plateau
c'est également le compagnon à la ville
un de la candidate une demi heure chacun
donc et avec moi pour les interroger ce
soir jean francis pécresse
bonsoir ce temps jean francis le
directeur de la rédaction de radio
classique et puis guillaume daudin de l'
agence france-presse
guillaume bonsoir messieurs vous êtes
prêt très bien vite et c'est jean paul
delevoye qui entrent sur ce plateau
[Musique]
monsieur de loi bonsoir à vous et merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous on vous
extraits de vos travaux de la commission
d'investiture on va en parler dans un
instant ancien ministre je le rappelle
c'est et en 2002 vous avez rejoint
emmanuel macron qui vous est donc chargé
des investitures des candidats dans
marche 2002 2010 est le front
républicain s'est affaibli face au front
national
et il ya quelques instants on a appris
donc que les 240 milles insoumis
militants de jean luc mélenchon ont voté
et ils annoncent leur choix pour
l'abstention ou le vote blanc les deux
tiers d'entre eux un tiers seulement
pour un vote macron c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle danse est révélateur en réalité
un faux regarder celle de la dynamique
quand on a analysé les scrutins des
primaires en fin de compte la gauche qui
était sûr de perdre a sorti le candidat
le plus à gauche et la droite qui était
sûr de gagner a sorti le candidat le
plus à droite et donc nous avons lorsque
nous consultons les militants les
pollutions les positions les plus
excessives d'une partie d'un électorat
vous inquiète pas ce mot parce qu'elles
ne reflètent pas en aucun cas la société
la preuve en est si vous prenez les
primaires les deux candidats ont eu la
même attitude
on ne touche pas à mon programme et on
s'est rendu compte que c'est rapidement
le décalage entre la société et ce qu'il
disait était de plus en plus grands
la seconde chose c'est que c'est tout à
fait normal que la partie la plus
mobilisée d'un électorat très très
radicaliser s'exprime de façon
extrêmement importante et donc quand
vous pouvez déjà y aurait au moins alors
qu'ensuite on puisse s'interroger sur le
nom de responsables responsables
politiques qui ne mesurent pas les
conséquences de leurs positions ça a été
vrai temps je n'ai cessé de dénoncer que
par un certain nombre de personnes
politiques qui ne mesurent pas les
dégâts qu'ils font dans la société par
la violence de leur propre donner des
noms oui oui non mais ça qu'on va donner
l'un concerne toute la classe politique
j'ai souvent indiqué dans mes positions
publique qu'il y avait des incendiaires
qui ne mesurait pas la violence des
propos qu'il tenait mêlant le mercredi
après midi par le jeu politicien dans
l'opinion
les gens s'interrogent en disant mais
comment se fait-il qu'on nous demande de
respecter les autorités quant eux mêmes
ont un comportement aussi radicale
et puis ensuite on a vu la dérive
droitière de monsieur fillon qui a cac
qui a changé entre sa sortie les
primaires et dernier discours qu'il
prononce est convaincu que la
droitisation de la société était en
marche qu'il fallait mais d'après la
jetée macro radical et non mais attendez
je rends hommage au discours qu'il a
tenu parce que malgré cela dès le soir
même
monsieur valls monsieur fillon ont pris
très clairement position pour monsieur
macro et quand je vois des responsables
comme monsieur mélenchon prisonnier d'un
électorat qui n'osent pas affirmer ce
qu'est aujourd'hui l'intérêt de la
france je pense souvent à cette phrase
de michel rocard qui lisait est ce que
le politique doit guider le peuple ou
suivre le peuple monsieur delevoye est
ce que vous parlez d'incendiaires est ce
que à sa manière emmanuel macron en
refusant tout compromis sur son
programme en disant que son programme de
premier tour sera le programme sur
lequel il sera peut-être élu dimanche
prochain est ce que lui ne contribue pas
à ce mouvement de jean luc mélenchon et
de ses militants
parce qu'en réalité il a une méthode et
une cohérence
on voit bien que la demande qui a été
faite de monsieur mélenchon en dix ans
nous avons été battus par le scrutin
démocratique et parce que nous avons été
battus nous souhaiterions si jamais on
vous rejoins que vous puissiez intégrer
une partie des raisons pour lesquelles
nous avons été battus c'est une demande
qui vient de la droite aussi nathalie
kosciusko morizet dit la même chose
alors ils ont oublié la méthode des
manuels vacant ce qui est tout à fait
intéressant et qui voit m'intéresse
beaucoup
ce qu'emmanuel macron à fixer un cap
quelle personne ne croyait il ya encore
10 mois il a proposé un programme qui
rassemble et la droite et la gauche et
les hommes et les femmes de bonne
volonté en leur 2e en leur disant
ensuite
attention il y aura une méthode dans les
six mois je veux être prêt vis-à-vis des
élections législatives allemandes pour
montrer la capacité qu'a la france de se
réformer structurellement sur en chômage
flexibilité du travail puis ensuite sur
cinq ans voire sur dix ans une forme de
grenelle pour travailler ensemble sur le
système des retraites peut-être sur le
système de la fiscalité et emmanuel
macron a très clairement indiqué que ce
qu'il fallait c'était ne pas juger les
hommes par leur passé mais par leur
capacité à pouvoir débattre pour
construire ensemble de position donc je
suis convaincu que quand il ya un mois
qu'il ya 102 position aujourd'hui qui
fixe un cap c'est quand je n'en saurai
si et dans lequel leur débat
parlementaire pourra ensuite un rêve aux
abricots après l'élection
après les malheurs jean-francis est ce
qu'on peut construire précisément une
majorité de projets autour d'eux monde
ordonnance puisque manifestement
emmanuel bach on veut dès cet été ont
engagé des ordonnances et notamment pour
résumer le travail est ce que c'est une
bonne méthode vraiment est ce que parce
que c'est très critiquée à gauche comme
à droite bien sûr mais l'on voit bien
qu'il ya un problème d'urgence
c'est à dire que nous avons sous-estimé
le regard international qui était porté
sur la france et la formidable
interrogations je voyais michel barnier
relativement peu de temps qui me disait
que la totalité des dirigeants européens
s'interrogeait pour savoir s'il n'avait
pas se tromper une troisième fois le pré
sident trump et madame le pen en france
deuxième élément l'image qu'a su donner
monsieur fillon par un certain nombre de
propos et de et de fautes qu'il a
commises a complètement décrédibilisée
l'image de la france sur le plan
international et puis aujourd'hui nous
avons absolument besoin akouala pardon
au nom mais je pense oui
si vous voulez la communauté
internationale n'a cessé de nous
critiquer de nous ridiculiser 1 0 vous
qui passez votre temps donner des leçons
et et de des fichiers des principes et
bien on s'aperçoit que dans nos pays
saxons ce type de comportement n'aurait
pas résisté trois jours et recourir à
des ordonnances et enjamber le parlement
est ce que c'est pas
parce que quelque chose qui pourrait
être critique et même à l'international
sauf qu'il ya un caractère d'urgence est
neutre qui ne trahit pas l'esprit je
viens à cela sur l'esprit je crois que
vous avez indiqué que connaît pas les
oublier le fait que monsieur peut
vaincre on souhaite mettre en place une
présidence qui rassemble qui gouvernent
mais qui délègue complètement à 15
ministres avec un sermon de secrétaire
d'état sans décret d'attribution pour
qu'ils et une feuille de route sur les
cinq ans avec une trajectoire budgétaire
reconnu par chacun il risque alors de
rentrer crédit par contre il y à une
urgence dans les six mois à faire en
sorte que très rapidement nous puissions
créer un choc permettant aux
entrepreneurs de pouvoir investir en
mesurant les conséquences de leurs
investissements embauché en mesurant les
conséquences des licenciements et faire
en sorte aussi que sur la protection
nous puissions donner un peu plus de
pouvoir d'achat aux retraités modestes
et aux salariés connaissent par le 31 on
a compris on comprend la démarche claire
à ce sujet je crois qu'effectivement il
y a une capacité à créer un choc
permettant d'enclencher une machine
permettant de redonner une confiance qui
une fois le parlement stabiliser je vous
rappelle que nous avons 50% minimum de
gens issus de la société civile qui
eux-mêmes bon on a compris quand on a
une véritable majorité ça sert à quoi de
faire une ordonnance parce que c'est pas
forcément plus rapide il faut les
habilités après ça prend plusieurs mois
en fait il ya le risque de la rue après
ce qui s'est passé le 1er mai avec les
événements être extrêmement violent vous
l'avez vu un certain promettent donne
déjà rendez-vous à emmanuel macron le
lendemain tu tournes éventail de peines
vos critiques une loi elle conneries
puissance mille
elle dit aussi qu'on va avoir louis
aliot après que voilà la violence vous
parlez d'un choc vous même ça risque
parce que ce ne sont pas des contre
arguments tel un boomerang dont le
second tour oui on voit bien que déjà se
prépare
la volonté de résister à un changement
et à la beta morphose de la société
française nous souhaitons nous ne pas
heurter de comprenons bien les peurs les
inquiétudes les angoisses mais nous
mesurons aussi qu'il est extrêmement
important de retrouver rapidement un
chemin d'espérance parce qu'il y aura un
retour d'investissement parce qu'il y
aura des créations d'emplois et parce
qu'il y aura des perspectives nouvelles
il ne vous a pas échappé que nous sommes
dans un moment de très grande
instabilité et donc de chopes obligé de
prendre des mesures pour créer ce choc
nécessaires permettant de prendre
devront emprunter le bon choix et
ensuite de retrouver des dialogues
citoyens des dialogues parlementaire
avec d'ailleurs une autre
un autre rôle qui sera donné au
parlement le fait d'évaluer le fait de
pouvoir expérimenter notre objectif
c'est de responsabiliser les territoires
de responsabiliser chacun et chacune de
nos concitoyens pour leur dire nous
sommes prêts au débat nous sommes prêts
à votre écoute nous sommes prêts à vous
allez on comprend la démarche encore une
fois mais pour réussir ce pari d'une
certaine manière il faut que emmanuel
macron soit largement élu dimanche un
oui quel est le score par exemple il
faut qu'ils aient combien de points
d'écart avec sa suivante oui on voit
bien tous les sondages un jeu pensé vous
équipant un emmanuel macron élus à 60 ou
élus à 55 c'est pas la même france et
c'est pas les mêmes perspectives et même
67 prison je pense que plus il sera
élevé le score et plus il permettra non
pas de méprise et cédiez ce que vous
était contre lui
il faut entendre celles et ceux qui
votent pour madame le pen celles et ceux
qui ont voté pour monsieur mélenchon il
ya une forme de contestation du système
que moi même d'ailleurs en tant que
médiateur est bien le publier en temps
je dénonce donc aujourd'hui nous devons
nous sommes extrêmement attentifs au
fait que nous avons fait 23% et qu'en
face de nous si on raisonne bien il ya
40 % de gens en colère et insoumis qu'il
va falloir convaincre mobilisées et
seule pourra se faire que par des
résultats et un dynamisme rapide est ce
que vous comprenez qu'une bonne partie
de l'électorat de droite continue de
voir en emmanuel macron l'héritier de
françois hollande ils disent au fond il
va faire la même politique que celle
qu'a fait pendant cinq ans françois
françois hollande
on va bien le caractère très très
simpliste un certain nombre de débats le
fait que quelqu'un ait quitté le
gouvernement fait que à l'époque on ne
pouvait pas dire que monsieur chirac
était jusqu à redire il a invité
monsieur giscard il ya des éléments de
contenu et l'on voit bien que ce qui est
intéressant c'est que monsieur macron
kit monsieur hollande quitte la fonction
publique prend un certain nombre de
risques personnels lancent un mouvement
auquel personne ne croyait c'est tout à
fait fascinant que cet homme était
considéré comme une bulle comme un
phénomène transitoire qui allait faire
pschitt
et puis maintenant qu'il obtient un
certain crédit parce que 250 milles
soutien c'est quand même une des
premières forces politiques le fait
qu'ils étaient aux premières en premier
en première position au premier tour des
élections présidentielles alors que déjà
tout le monde a annoncé deuxième voire
troisième fait qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui il doit trouver c'est ça
l'intérêt de notre rassemblement
retournement différemment en quoi est-ce
que son projet est si différent de ce
qu'a fait françois hollande pendant cinq
ans lorsque l'on peut dire c'est c'est
le françois hollande du début de la fin
c'est le virage non mais expliquez moi
parce qu'on voit bien que lui-même
françois hollande est très clairement
changé de cap
au point d'ailleurs que cela a créé les
frondeurs c'est plutôt le dernier
françois hollande celui qui t'intéresse
de la politique de l'offre c'est que
c'est l'atlantique vite et dès la
dernière politique en le françois
hollande qui consiste à dire il faut
trouver le moyen d'augmenter la
compétitivité de l'offre alors les uns
pensent que c'est dans l'abaissement du
coût du travail ça c'est le propre
proposition qui était dans programme de
monsieur fillon
nous nous avons au contraire c'est là la
plus value des manuels lac rond nous
avons effectivement cette partie
d'abaisser le coût du travail mais aussi
de considérer qu'un des freins à la
création d'emplois c'est la faiblesse de
la formation c'est la faiblesse de
l'éducation c'est le faible est de
compétence au point d'ailleurs que dans
un certain nombre de régions comme le
note croissance comme le nord le taux de
croissance est bien imité par l'absence
d'ingénieurs notamment dans l'économie
du numérique et le cdo avait rendu
d'études tout à fait intéressante qui
faisait que sur 9% de chômage
eh bien il estimé qu'il y avait quelques
fois entre 6 et 7% de chômage nos
réductible uniquement par un défaut de
l'adéquation de compétences et de besoin
d'eux
de l'industrie du numérique de françois
hollande en fin de quinquennat souffre
d'un rejet massif et pourtant peut-être
emmanuel macron va être élu comment il
va faire justement pour ne pas souffrir
de ce rejet massif alors même que
peut-être il a appliqué une politique
assez comparables assez dans la
continuité
chacun a compris qu emmanuel macron
tirer le meilleur du bilan de monsieur
sarkozy et tirer le meilleur du bilan de
monsieur hollande
et ça on peut pas lui reprocher c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est à dire que
déjà ils changent de 8,8 dès qu'un
président est élu son obsession c'était
de faire différemment de celui qui lui
prenait ce qui le précède qui le
précédait et c'est ça que l'on veut
casser qu'est-ce qui va garder de
benesova sarkozy sa géopolitique
abattant des la dimension européenne
il faut pas oublier la pas été absente
du dernier quinquennat sarkozy recevait
le système bancaire sur une régulation
ont réveillé la ville la fin des enjeux
de la dimension internationale qui nous
faut absolument reconquérir
c'est la régulation monétaire c'est la
régulation d'un capitalisme que jardiner
est totalement dérégulé et c'est
l'obligation de trouver des règles qui
fasse que le capitalisme ne sont pas un
accélérateur de la destruction de
l'environnement et de l'évolution des
ressources humaines quand est-ce qu'on
connaîtra la liste des candidats
investis
c'est votre charge notre responsabilité
à nous en respectant les critères un pas
de casier judiciaire de la parité à
parité pour les circonscriptions
gagnables pour les femmes de plus de 50
% de la société civile
notre responsabilité c'est de fournir au
conseil d'administration présidé par
emmanuel macron la totalité des
candidats je pense dans les jours qui
viennent soyez attendant les jours qui
nous sommes en train de terminer avant
le second tour au salon mais je pense
que demain nous aurons à peu près mais
ils vont terminer demain vous avez
terminé la quasi-totalité to serve à
plus de 500 circonscription qui ont été
étudiées donc tous sommes aujourd'hui à
vincent sur 577
on est pressé il ya quelques portes qui
restent ouvertes ou qui sont sous verte
maintenant pour quelques-uns et
notamment manuel valls combien de temps
est-ce que ces portes vont rester
ouvertes
la force des manuels macron c'est sa
cohérence et qu'il n'y ait aucune
ambiguïté et l'on voit bien qu'il ya
toute une série de jeux politiques elle
consiste à dire je suis macro
compatibles et témoin des candidats
relativement faibles etc
nous nous disons votre choix c'est votre
choix nous le respectons et vous en
assumer les conséquences
nous nous proposons un projet
présidentiel incarné par un président si
vous décidez de le soutenir
vous adhérez à en marche vous vous
inscrivez à la préfecture sur
l'investiture en marche et les choses
sont très claires si vous décidez de
rester dans vos appareils politiques et
bien à ce moment là nous constatons ce
choix et nous mettrons un candidat veut
être candidat en marche il faut qu'ils
passent par la procédure normale avec
une lettre ils vous envoient un cv aux
candidatures reçues son cv auprès de la
toulousaine a écrit encore avec une
lettre de motivation vous avez créé
encore n'ont pas encore encore
toute candidature doit être analysée
pour être analysés doit passer par le
site en marche
même richard ferrand le fait d'accord
mais vous avez entendu la réaction de
marine le pen ça n'a pas traîné
1 quand emmanuel macron et dit
qu'effectivement du recyclage manuel
valls pour être candidat dans marche
marine le pen ceinture et lycées du
recyclage des socialistes n'y a pas de
renouvellement
je pense que c'est un cliché parce qu'en
réalité quand elle reprend elle même des
anciens du du rpr qui viennent la
rejoindre ce que j'ai du recyclage
non c'est simplement des hommes et des
femmes qui font leur choix et qui estime
qu'il ya un projet à défendre et pour
lequel il souhaite s'engager tout nous
estimons que nous n'avons pas à
critiquer l'origine personnes non nous
demandons à personne de renier son passé
de ce tueur simplement de l'oublier le
maximum pas du tout comme un beau nier
son passé mais de ne pas être la risée
gérer sa carte par un autre prisonnier
ou heller d'ailleurs attendez vous avez
toute une série c'est pas où je vais
apprendre qu'il ya toute une série de
gens qui lors de l'élection du pr du
premier tour n'était pas très à l'aise
au parti socialiste et n'était pas l'air
très à l'aise à droite et donc
aujourd'hui nous souhaitons la
clarification de l'offre politique et
nos concitoyens critiqué le système
depuis très longtemps
ce qu'à gauche les gens ne s'entendait
pas sauf pour le pouvoir et à droite les
gens ne s'entendait pas sauf pour le
pouvoir
il faut arrêter ça il faut la démocratie
c'est un débat d'idées c'est un choix de
conviction et nous proposons un système
très clair si vous partagez de
conviction nous vous accueillons
et vous prenez lévitique est en marche
si vous ne partagez pas nous le co ne au
contraire nous nous allons nous enrichir
de vos différences et nous allons
pouvoir peut-être mettre en place de
nouvelles formes de désaccord a écrit
aux parlementaires y compris
parlementaires parce que ça ne vous a
pas échappé que sur les plateaux vous
savez très bien que quand la personne de
droite va dire blanc l'autre dira noir
nous nous disions annonce
l'enrichissement de ses différents c'est
pas toujours évident quand il s'agit de
gouverner le pays et je crois qu'il va
falloir il va falloir faire on va même
mettre en place des pratiques nouvelles
sur le plan du débat citoyen et en sorte
que les citoyens nous puissions leur
offrir par nos candidats les moyens de
pouvoir éventuellement se construire des
convictions on ne pourra plus gérer un
pays sûr des émotions
sinon on aura des cimes du mot politique
qui seront redoutables essayé au vrai
concrètes vous dites que la liste sera
bouclée peut-être demain est ce qu'elle
sera aussi public demain avant le avant
le second tour alors questions concrètes
réponse concrète la commission a pour
vocation de proposer au conseil
d'administration la liste des candidats
et la décision politique et maître de
l'horloge
bon on attendre alors on attendra encore
un petit peu et ses potes je ne peux pas
vous répondre
moi mon job avec la commission qui
composaient d'ailleurs de six femmes et
de trois hommes donc à parité largement
respecté totalement indépendante qui
subit beaucoup de pression mais qui a pu
vous arrêter un peu avec des tas de gens
qui souhaitent savoir ou qui veulent
nous
soutenir tel ou tel personne et c'est
normal eh bien je suis tout à fait
frapper par sa sérénité et la force de
conviction qui anime nos débats c'est
pas toujours facile on prend ces 500
heures de préparation et ses 120 heures
de débats eh bien nous avons à la
proposition qui va être faite au conseil
d'administration de dire voilà les 577
candidats que nous estimons à la hauteur
du projet que vous portez il vous
appartient maintenant de les dévoiler ou
de ne pas les avec la moitié de nos vies
ce lorrain je pense que nous serons tous
au dessus au dessus de 50% pas des
novices part apprécié non ce sont des
novices en matière politique oui mais 77
pourtant 77% ont déjà des engagements
associatifs quelquefois municipaux
quelquefois départementaux je rappelle
que c'est il s'agit de plus de 50%
c'est la première élection législative
mais ces nouvelles avaient commencé le
travail sur les sénatoriales qui
arriveront assez vite dans cette année
2010 ne mélangeons pas les cinq ans vous
a pas échappé que cette séquence
législative
lorsqu'il faudra réorganiser le
mouvement et ensuite préparer les
prochaines échéances nous nous y
préparons effectivement pour les
sénatoriales et municipales et
départementales avec les mêmes règles
à libé quelle merveille même règle
depuis le 24 avril par toute une série
de gestes et de phrases emmanuel macron
c'était forcé de redit à baud lisez le
front national est ce que c'est la bonne
manière de faire sachant que toute une
génération de votants aujourd'hui n'a
pas connu l'histoire du fn et l'histoire
de l'extrême droite française et à cette
génération au fond on a l'impression que
ça ne parle pas que ça ne fait pas peur
est ce que c'est la bonne manière de
faire moins bien d'ailleurs que ce que
vous évoquez c'est la belle chose que la
résonance qui lie à l'europe a permis la
paix pour toute une série de génération
qui n'a pas connu la guerre
donc nous avons en fin de compte à jouer
sur plusieurs tableaux
un de montrer qu un choix politique
c'est pas anodin pour développer un
certain nombre d' idéologie qui peuvent
être suicidaire pour un pays savez le
philosophe a dit les nations ne meurt
pas mais elles peuvent se suicider et
nous sommes aujourd'hui un carrefour de
l'histoire on peut parfaitement retrouvé
le rejet de l'autre je lisais d'ailleurs
dans un article d'un de vos confrères
la corrélation qui avait entre la
république de weimar et l'époque
actuelle c'était la même chose c'était
la corruption des élites c'était
je voudrais reprendre pour que les
choses soient claires un esprit du temps
qui était un pessimisme à l'époque tout
le monde pensait qu'il y avait un
déclinisme que l'avenir était incertain
et la haine de l'autre avec des boucs
émissaires les mêmes phénomènes
produisent les mêmes effets nous sommes
dans un moment où nous pouvons avoir des
réflexes suicidaire plus faut penser
monde plus on porte ce village puis faut
penser moyen terme
plus on pense court terme et plus faut
penser l'autre et plus on pense chaque
artiste que les électeurs dimanche une
passe se déterminer sur des
problématiques tout simplement plus
concrète alors c'est ce que j'allais
vous dire effectivement il ya donc toute
cette partie du passé et d'éclairer les
citoyens sur le chou et 4,5 et dans le
jura une d'emmanuel mac et puis il ya
aujourd'hui des problématiques très
concrète le pouvoir d'achat les
problématiques de santé les
problématiques de service public le
sentiment un peu d'abandons des espaces
ruraux et c'est toute autre partie de la
conduction des manuels macro et de
celles et ceux qui l'entourent de
montrer qu'en réalité le programme
économique de madame le pen est
absolument pas crédible personne
n'imagine aujourd'hui en plus le temps
j'ai cru comprendre qu'il y avait deux
monnaies l'euro et le franc s'est pas
financer 1 3 et donc avec les cubains et
avec les culs aussi donc plus personne
n'y comprend rien si ce n'est que les
conséquences seront catastrophiques pour
justement et c'est cela qu'il nous faut
des dossiers c'est la supercherie mais
madame le pen cherche à être proche du
peuple
alors qu'elle est issue du système
emmanuel macron a quitté ex mister
madame le pen dit mais ne vous inquiétez
pas je vais vous protéger en réalité en
supprimant tout ce qui assure depuis
vingt ans la protection des françaises
et des français mais les précaires dans
une situation encore plus précaire
c'est l'explosion de notre système de
santé c'est l'exposition la technologie
on veut augmenter un certain nombre
d'allocations qu'elle veut une prime de
pouvoir d'achat c'est comme ça et vous
savez monsieur hugo chavez avait promis
il fait les mêmes promesses au venezuela
il faut regarder aujourd'hui où en est
le pays est ce que ce sont les arguments
qui seront utilisés par votre candidat
demain soir lors du fameux débat de
l'entre-deux tours est ce que comme il
se prépare est ce que vous redoutez ce
rendez-vous non contre cette
confrontation je suis ravi
ah bon il est un débat belle et très
agressive vous avez
vu pour te faire en permanence et son
style et la démocratie c'est de défendre
aussi d hommes et de femmes qui ne
pensent pas comme vous c'était la
position de voltaire moi je n'ai jamais
critiquer quelqu'un qui avaient voté
front national
j'ai toujours demandé aux partis
politiques traditionnels de s'interroger
des raisons pour lequel parce qu'ils
étaient pas bon dans les résultats il
faisait en sorte que les deux moyens
d'exprimer la colère la désespérance
était à l'abstention et le vote du front
national heureusement que monsieur macro
et là peut offrir une alternative est ce
que avoir été banquier banquier chez
rothschild c'est un atout c'est un
handicap dans cette campagne il faut
revendiquer son passé c'est absolument
fascinant de voir que quelqu'un qui a
réussi dans les affaires devraient dire
avait coûté jeu il aurait été préférable
que j'échoue dans les affaires pour que
vous puissiez me trouvais sympathique
je crois qu'il est important que
quelqu'un connaisse vient des mécanismes
bancaires pour mieux peser dans les
décisions moi je m'inquiète beaucoup
des hommes et des femmes qui affirment
tout savoir alors qu'ils ne savent rien
le monde est tellement compliquée qu'à
voir des hommes et des femmes capables
de comprendre et surtout au delà de son
passé de banquiers ce qui me fascine
chez monsieur macron c'est sa capacité
de s'entourer de compétences et vu que
quand il a sorti son programme
économique que tout le monde attendait
ça a été saluée par tous sur dix ans
c'est le plus crédible c'est le plus
raisonnable en termes de taux de
croissance c'est celui qui inspire le
plus de confiance et d' équilibre entre
les précaires les défavorisés et celles
et ceux qui veulent ta veste et en même
temps on a du mal à y voir une ligne
dans ce projet économique
alors elle a caractérisé cette ligne
très claire c'est un pur avant de
distribuer faut créer des richesses
notre france a perdu beaucoup de poids
en termes de compétitivité y compris en
termes d'équipement nous sommes un des
pays les plus faibles en matière
d'équipement de robots et aujourd'hui
retrouver cette capacité d'investir de
croire dans l'avenir de libérer les
initiatives
moi je connais je la prétention de
connaître un peu la france il n'y a
jamais autant d'intelligence
autant d'innovations mais on met une
intelligence administrative à vous
expliquer pourquoi on ne peut pas faire
si on libère tous à la générosité des
citoyens l'intelligence des citoyens la
créativité l'innovation des
entrepreneurs ça peut transformer
complètement le pays en quelques
affiches on revient sur le débat de
demain soir on a lu cet après midi qu
emmanuel macron pourrait quitter le
plateau si jamais le débat devenait trop
tendu trop agressif vous nous confirmer
que ça pourrait se produire
je suis incapable de vous dire cela mais
je pense qu emmanuel macron n'a jamais
reculé devant telle agressivité et qu'il
affrontera idée contre idée qu'il aura
le souci de effectivement clarifier les
conséquences du choix du front national
par rapport à l'histoire et les
par rapport à la vie alors le front
national justement en ce moment marine
le pen notamment la cus souvent d'être
lui-même très très agressif très
impulsive dans ses réactions
il fait tourner en boucle les images de
ces meetings où on voit un peu à la fin
sans porter s'enthousiasmer c'est selon
vous vous craignez un peu ça de votre
candidat je crois que le débat de demain
sera un débat de fond plus que de forme
c'est vrai que madame le pen a plutôt
l'habitude de la ford de l'agressivité
verbale et et du verbe et non pas du
fond on a l'habitude des échanges
parfois tendues bien sûr plus peut-être
que manuellement emmanuel macron a le
souci du respect de la bienveillance
mais aussi de la conviction
c'est un homme qui souhaite avoir un
débat sur le fond pour montrer nos
concitoyens que la france peut peser sur
le destin du monde dans un moment où
celui ci est complètement instable
est ce qu'il pourra parler à la france
populaire comme lui demandé xavier
bertrand bien sûr il faut qu'ils parlent
ils le font populaire c'est quelque
chose d'important il a parlé dans son
discours de dimanche de la famille il a
parlé des situations précaires les
solidaires j'ai été très frappée d'un
sondage ou et je regardais cela c'est
86% des français ont un lien fort
d'appartenance à la nation française
mais dans leur quotidien 62% pensent
qu'une fracture entre les riches et les
pauvres 61% entre les citoyens les
élites 50% une fracture éducatif
d'autres pays est en train se fragmenter
se déchiraient et demain il va proposer
entre les jeunes et les anciens entre et
donc le besoin tout ça c'est d'apaiser
de rassembler et de mobilis monsieur
macron c'est celui qui va résorber la
fracture entre les riches et les pauvres
entre les pros la province et paris les
je pense qu'il a cette capacité en
mobilisant les acteurs locaux en
mobilisant les acteurs sociaux
mobilisant les investisseurs de faire en
sorte
que nous retrouvions une communauté de
destin et non pas une communauté
d'intérêts aujourd'hui généralement les
gens votent pour un politique en
fonction de la préservation de sa niche
fiscale ou de ce qu'il va lui apporter
c'est certes humain mais aujourd'hui il
faut que nous retrouvions le champ de la
nation là ma question est très concrète
les rangées oui la fracture entre les
riches et les pauvres qui a eu tendance
à grandir je pense qu'il faut que nous
retrouvions cette capacité d'apaiser de
même que les perdants et les gagnants et
de même que de la stigmatisation de
l'échec
moi ce qui m'avait beaucoup frappé chez
bunuel macron c'est sa philosophie la
confiance dans l'homme je partager la
même école que lui et la police ans
damien c'est de mettre à quel point que
quand il choisit l'école comme facteur
prioritaire de sa politique c'est pas eu
du plaisir à les syndicats au contraire
c'est de dire l'éveil de l'intelligence
c'est la clé de la réussite de la france
de demain
vous connaissez bien vous êtes proche de
jean louis borloo un proche vous le
connaissez vous avez très tôt de dîner
avec lui un point ici de le ramener
du côté des remarques finalement ça
c'est fait on a vu ça son interview dans
le journal du dimanche qu'elle roule
pourrait-il jouer demain il paraît que
emmanuel macron a déjà deux noms de
premiers ministres jean louis borloo est
un personnage politique qui a un à
quelque chose d'assez fait six ans que
je retrouvais chez jacques chirac c'est
l'affectif
les gens l'aiment bien la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il a un savoir faire il sait
faire le grenelle de l'environnement
rassembler les hommes et les femmes
différents pour travailler ça aussi
c'est une méthode qui va inspirer manuel
pour s y avait là qui pourrait servir à
mettre à matignon je l'avais ma question
c'est est qu'ils pourraient servir à
matignon absolument ne soyez pas
fatigués par les titres par les
fonctions ce qui est un trac en mer 16
ans disait c2c que c'est clair que le
choix du gouvernement sera déterminant
pour le crédit que accordera de façon
supplémentaire l'opinion par rapport aux
listes est une raison de plus pour le
donner avant le premier tour et il était
justement le second tour par toutes ces
pressions mais je laisse ça à baigneaux
micron qui m'a fasciné par les
intuitions qui étaient les siennes
c'est un homme qui a des acquisitions
extraordinaire personne ne croyait en
lui sauf lui il a réussi à réussir il a
réussi à enclencher une offre politique
auquel personne ne croyait et qui est
aujourd'hui porteur d'espérance on a
parlé effectivement un de hold up de
l'arrêt vème république
le castrais 5e république avec son
irruption dans les cordes il revendique
le fait que l'explosion il a cassé
l'offre politique khalil pour pouvoir
permettre une réorganisation plus clair
plus cohérent de l'offre par éthique
il a raison on vous laisse maintenant à
parce que vous êtes encore quelques
dizaines de noms à coucher sur la liste
je te disais donc quelques dizaines plus
beaucoup vous ne l'avez dit avant
soixante dix absolument à merci beaucoup
merci à vous merci jean paul delevoye
d'avoir été avec nous deuxième invité de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant c'est
louis aliot le vice président du front
national à qui vous laissez votre place
au revoir j'espère qu'elle sera
confortable
[Musique]
bonsoir écouter le fauteuil confortable
nos émotions nos questions n'ont aucune
raison de l'être
c'est la règle du jeu vous l'acceptez
j'en parlais tout à l'heure de la
décision des militants de la france
insoumise donc finalement leur
consultation donne deux tiers pour le
vote blanc ou l'abstention un tiers
seulement appelle à voter macron est-ce
que cela conforte notre stratégie on a
entendu marine le pen multiplié les
appels du pied sipa une stratégie c'est
la réalité d'un électorat qui s'est
constitué contre le pouvoir en place de
monsieur hollande contre la politique
gouvernementale contre la politique
européenne et qui est assez logique
je trouve avec avec lui même c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'on pouvait reprocher
jusqu'à présent aux gens qui votaient
mélenchon où il faisait des campagnes
très très viril on va dire à l'égard des
socialistes un général du parti
socialiste et de ses alliés mais
systématiquement d'aller second tour on
pouvait considérer qu'ils allaient à la
soupe en appeler à voter deuxième au
deuxième tour le socialiste quelle que
soit la situation
là je dois dire c'est la première fois
que ça se passe et je trouve ça très
simple et très certainement ça aura des
conséquences sur la recomposition
politique avait vous avez salué la
dignité 1 de jean luc mélenchon soir du
premier tour là vous disent la même
chose la même vous parlez quoi de
dignité pour les militants de la france
info - je parle de logique voire les
deux logiques
vous pensez que les électeurs vont
suivre ce vote des militants c'est quoi
une hausse de + 3 5 milles vers ce que
je crois deux cent quarante mille deux
cents can il s'adonne comme un
échantillon représentatif de ce qui a
été son électorat quand même et donc je
pense que ça peut être effectivement une
image une photographie de ce que seront
les votes de ce que voter mélenchon pour
le deuxième tour de cette élection
présidentielle en france s dans les
échos ce matin plusieurs entrepreneurs
prennent position de manière très claire
contre votre projet économique en gros
ils disent soit c'est un projet inepte
soit il évincé l'un et l'autre
d'ailleurs assez souvent il est à la
fois il est et il est catastrophique
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire ce qu'est ce que ça vous fait
douter quand même delà de la pertinence
de vos propositions économiques ou
est-ce que vous restez vraiment sur
votre projet ça fait pas douter mais il
faut regarder avec attention
dis quand même maintenant je trouve qu'à
une énorme différence entre ce que j'ai
pu lire dans votre journal est ce qu'on
peut voir sur le terrain parce que par
exemple le ceux qui font les emplois
aujourd'hui ceux qui font l'économie
c'est aussi les petites entreprises
familiales s'exprimer pearson trudeau
qui disent je suis plutôt un accord est
ce que dit marine le pen parce qu'on
retrouvera beaucoup et bien moi je peux
vous dire que sur le terrain il y en a
la preuve c'est que les michael sala
c'est que c'est que sur le pourtour
méditerranéen dans le nord dans l'est
marine le pen fait quelquefois delà de
30% et 40% pour des régionales il ya des
chefs d'entreprise qui votent pour nous
donc tout ce qui lie à la une
on pourrait dire une forme de propagande
de électorales anti marine le pen
chiffon tenir compte mais je pense que
malheureusement ou heureusement dans
l'esprit aujourd'hui des français c'est
pas les entrepreneurs saison si vous
prenez marque la réussite de la france
quand même à tous les niveaux mais comme
à ce que je rappelle quand même que
certaines en être certains on avait
promis beaucoup d'emplois en raison
notamment du séisme excités qui a pas eu
d'emplois lac et donc les français
doutent et non mais les perspectives de
création en mai mois en france dans les
mois qui viennent sont très importants
il existe cinq ces deux derniers
baromètres de prêts à monsieur hollande
a été élu on nous a dit aussi qu'il est
plein de perspectives d'emploi et de
croissance on a vu le résultat moi je
suis un peu comme comme saint thomas je
ne crois que ce que je vois et pour
l'instant les économistes qui ont fait
des prévisions tout c'est en général
pendant les élections de risa ciel se
sont tous trompés lourdement
donc il faut prendre ça avec il faut le
prendre avec sérieux mais il faut le
prendre c'est qu'une certaine distance
parce qu'ils n'ont pas toujours raison
est-ce que les attaques continuelles de
la droite notamment sur l'idée que le
programme de marie freineraient le même
que celui de monsieur mélenchon c'est
une sorte de boulet électoral pour pour
votre mouvement et pour marine le pen
non parce que
mêlant chants plus les eurosceptiques
divers et variés plus marine le pen plus
la partie de monsieur fillon qui n'est
pas très favorable à cette europe là ça
fait plus 50 % mais on ne s'est
peut-être pas si si nul que ça bien que
l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon qui
est plus classé très à gauche a besoin
de chance de vous rejoindre massifs ont
promis mais il s'agit il nous a rejoint
au moins une fois
c'est lors du référendum contre la
constitution en 2005 où là tous les
électorats se sont mélangés dans semaine
vote il y avait d'énormes de gauche des
noms de droite et ça fait un nom
majoritaire et là dans les idées en tout
cas on l'a vu au débat de premier tour
qu'il ya eu débat il y avait quand même
je ne sais pas combien de candidats
étaient hostiles à cette construction
européenne et donc à ce modèle
économique et c'est de ça dont monsieur
macron d'ailleurs et d'autres devraient
tenir compte parce que on fait comme si
ça n'existait pas ça fait dix ans qu'on
considère beau mais voilà c'est plus
d'europe
en recevant cobral de ce que veulent les
français et on continue comme avant
et le danger il est est bien de créer
des fractures très importante au sein de
la société française précisément sur
cette question là qu'on supprime alors
c'est intéressant parce que là vous êtes
en train de dénoncer l'europe l'europe
oui alors que le programme manifestement
n'est plus tout à fait celui ci n'est ce
pas alors c'est sûr de la sortie de la
route sur la sortie de l'euro qui est la
clé de voûte quand même de votre nom et
que mes commentaires alors attendez on
va parler celui foule qui est la clé de
voûte de votre projet économique on n'y
comprend plus rien on a pensé comprendre
qu' il y avait l'euro on allait passer
offrant maintenant on comprend qu'il ya
une sorte de mener commune mais qui
n'est plus la monnaie unique mais qui
est une unité de compte 20 est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer clairement
d'abord ce qui va se passer et quand
d'abord voilà on nous dira que je
l'électoralisme je trouve que les
commentaires politiques dans notre pays
n'est pas très attentif à ce que nous
disons je rappelle que la monnaie
commune de la beauté unique était déjà
présent dans le programme de marine le
pen en 2012
certains auraient pu prendre la
précaution d'aller lire bon ils n'ont
pas fait que le référendum était aussi
déjà dans les propositions de marine le
pen en 2012 mais là c'est une question
d'agenda et d'organisation le problème
de l'euro n'est que l'ombre des
problèmes de l'europe
il est important nous pensons qu'il est
essentiel mais il est un parmi d'autres
il faut renégocier l'europe entière le
système européen
le modèle économique européen et dans ce
modèle-là l'euro la monnaie et la
souveraineté monétaire est l'un des
éléments ce que vous dites
continuellement depuis plusieurs années
c'est que tout va ensemble justement que
lieux et l'euro votre négociation vous
souhaitez faire tout ceci va ensemble
donc en repoussant éventuellement la
négociation sur l'euro vous repoussez
les négociations sur le nouveau il faut
s'engager tout de suite de la
négociation de nouveaux traités en fait
avec l'union européenne et les
partenaires européens
qu'ils se rassurent les institutions
elles-mêmes européenne qui sera sur le
modèle économique
qu'ils se rassurent la protectionnisme
aux frontières etc
mais ça on ne peut le faire évidemment
que avec le soutien du peuple français
est tout de suite
d'ailleurs les négociations il faut que
ça engage tout de suite ce qui ne veut
pas dire tout de suite oui oui parce
qu'un certain nombre de mesures que vous
pouvez prendre tout de suite sans
attendre le référendum de vous dissocier
les deux négociations si je comprends
bien il ya tout d'abord tout un tas de
négociations sur la souveraineté
territoriale gociations en général nous
tiennent compte de paramètres pour en
revenir à l'euro tu dises un papier tout
à l'heure de monsieur arthur je pourrais
pas dire qu'il ait du front national il
a dit la zone monétaire l'euro la zone
de l'euro est vouée à l'échec la seule
manière c'est marqué j'ai l'article la
seule manière de s'en sortir c'est
d'aller vers un plus d'union monétaire
précisément et d'union budgétaire
c'est-à-dire le budget européen et à se
demander plus mais dans le cadre de
leurs hôtes année à moi sauf que bon
sens et l'euro personne n'en veut c'est
une utopie
si tous et au monde vous mêlant les
freins sont rejetées elles veulent
garder le haut si vous aller vers une
union budgétaire vous aller vers une
union européenne pays unitaire en
quelque sorte vous allez vers une europe
pays et à les français et beaucoup
d'autres peuples en europe n'en veulent
pas il faut aller vers une cogénération
d'état s'il faut aller en suisse
merci personne n'avait rien eu un vote
on a en france bien lieu à un vote sur
l'euro mais c'était en référendum sur
tout mais non c'est en les femmes ça
doit vous êtes ex tandis alors la
constitution européenne
elle avait évidemment les chapitres sur
l'union monétaire enfin ils ont très
concret évidemment marine le pen est
élue peut-être dimanche prochain
aussitôt elle engage la négociation sur
comme elle dit habituellement les quatre
souveraineté elle engage immédiatement
la négociation sur l'euro ou est ce que
la négociation sur l'euro vient plus
tard elle n'engage des négociations sur
l'ensemble des règles qui ont fondé
jusqu'ici l'union européenne
voilà mais sur le on récupère déjà les
frontières oui on peut donner du pouvoir
d'achat aux français dément modeste et
bien augmentant par exemple les
allocations pour les handicapés elle
financera la prime pour le pouvoir
d'achat
en faisant année dans les petites
entreprises en baisse en glissant les
tranches de l'impôt sur le revenu vous
dit comment en faisant des économies une
fille alors où est la chute est-ce que
sur les migrations et braillards deux
roues sur l'immigration l'économie mais
on les voit pas sur la fraude fiscale
sur la fraude sociale
ça prendra du temps mais vous êtes
extraordinaire et la fraude mais vous
crucial rapport de plus en plus d'argent
d'ailleurs mais tout ça est un longue ça
par utah mais ça prouve que ça peut
rapporter aussi des nouveaux dépenses
sur l'immigration supprimer la des
milliards
mais là pour les étrangers et ces
messieurs où l'europe sur sur l'euro
millions les petits ruisseaux font les
grandes rivières
cher monsieur voilà sentent milliards
d'euros ce que je veux vous dire par là
mais non tout rennes d'économie il est
de 80 milliards d'euros dans notre
projet mais le détail et dans votre rêve
parce que vous l'avez pas lui même s'il
assure le site
si vous ou si je dois vous le dire on va
prendre deux heures à l'oratoire dans
votre chiffrage dans les coins yap la
grille que non mais que vous allez si
nous de toute façon les gens il ya
souvent une opinion ils ont calé sur la
santé le vérificateur s'est cassé une
question précise et après ça j'allais
oublier l'argent que nous donnons à
l'aurore si on ne sort pas de llorente 1
milliard d'euros si on ne nous en reste
et une grande partie
c'est vraiment comme il est allé combien
mais ses rêves oui c'est ça y est le
reste on le donne à perte
oui mais une institution européenne qui
passe son temps que le barca qui a
organisé une concurrence déloyale qui
met nos agriculteurs nos entreprises et
nos services en grande difficulté alors
question pressé mais de nos jours c'est
à belmont gagne parce qu'on a tous
marchés européens tous les entrepreneurs
d'ailleurs des charges a cherché tout
bon matin faisait c'était moins bien il
leur répondit leur a causés aux étangs
hareng l'union européenne soyaux le
monde a changé et les entrepreneurs
aujourd'hui 17 600 changer les
entrepreneurs effectivement qui
s'expriment petits et grands dans les
échos devises que l'euro il ya un
certain leur apporte donc mais c'est
autre chose de ne pas vous dire si vous
prenez un journal les échos qui a passé
son temps pendant la campagne à
critiquer et à combattre marine le pen
veut donner passé ce journal un exemple
on pourra visiter d'autres allaient
d'excellents journal qui met les jeunes
qui ne fait pas de police ainsi quand
même un peu qui fait d'économies de
coûts qui fait de l'économie maintenant
mais c'est le restio il n'a jamais été
très lucide à l'économie verte il a
toujours soutenu ceux qui ont mis la
france dans les taureaux nés ce question
en question jean francis est facile
précise la sorte si vous ne sortez pas
de l'euro vous ne faites pas la taxe sur
les importations et vous ne faites pas
la taxe sur les salaires des étrangers
sur le suivre sur les travailleurs
étrangers
donc comment vous faites pour financer
ce que vous voulez mettre en oeuvre et
notamment les baisses d'impôts
dit en faisant des excédents 1001 porte
de votre projet violence à relancer la
machine économique
vous créez de la croix sarine mme le pen
22 du pouvoir d'achat marine le pen là
où 29 le 29 mars je crois que c'était ça
à peu près 10 et 100 sorties l'ue et de
l'euro
je ne peux pas faire 70% de mon
programme où il va être une urgence
c'est l'atelier a peut-être les 30% qui
reste satisfaisant puisque je vais vous
dire quelque chose doit être élue sur jv
bondir grande consommation de vin non
tout de suite tout de suite mais les 60
tout de suite après les négociations car
ça peut aller très vite
un pays comme la france qui est le
deuxième contributeur du budget de
l'union qu'il va dire la 2e ou 3e
économie de l'union européenne vous
imaginez si demain elle arrive avec le
mandat de renégocier l'europe
les partenaires à venir ne négocie pas
mais ça n'existera jamais c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé sur un
autre sujet dans d'autres circonstances
au moment où de gaulle a fait la fameuse
politique de la chaise vide et tout le
monde est venu discuter parce que
l'europe sans la france ça n'existe plus
il faudra donc refonder une autre union
européenne avec des choses qui existent
déjà avec des choses qui n'existent pas
encore mais en tenant compte de la
liberté des gouvernements des états de
décider pour eux-mêmes et de pas être et
ne pas être contraints à la régie vite
et de normes et de position notamment de
la commission qui est nommée lui avoir
questions sur le délai dernière question
on n'a pas compris ces derniers temps il
ya eu tout un tas de déclarations et
marine le pen a dit par exemple ça
commencerait après les élections
allemandes donc peut-être à l'automne
marion maréchal a dit ça commencerait
après les élections italienne les
négociations peut être en début 2018
alors quand est-ce que ça comment vous
vous dites tout tout de suite sans délai
alors où est ce que c est évident que
marine le pen élue dimanche les
premières
mesure et peut être les premiers voyages
qui serez fait serait pour aller
précisément préciser à nos partenaires
européens
la manière dont on veut changer les
choses en europe mais ça irait très vite
ça irait très vite le délai de la
négociation regardez appartement où vous
art où vous actionnez l'article 50
je pense à l'angleterre ça prend du
temps deux ans ça prend du temps mais ça
c'est autre chose ça c'est la complexité
juridique et constitutionnel des traités
qu'il faut améliorer ce temps là c'est
pas le sujet le sujet c'est qu'est ce
que nous voulons comme europe pour
demain et nous ce sera un grand débat
pour précisément refonder l'europe parce
qu'on a toujours dit qu'il y avait deux
modèles européens qui s'affrontent et
mais depuis toujours
ça a été le modèle de jean monnet et ça
a été le modèle de de gaulle et c'est
jean monnet qui l'a emporté sur deux
volets bien faut revenir précisément à
l'europe que vous voulez charles de
gaulle c'est à dire l'europe des
coopérations et des projets alors on
danse me laurence quand même sur la
sortie du royaume uni de l'union
européen précisément puisque vous ont
parié la croissance britannique au
premier trimestre 2010 est à plonger
sous l'effet de la dépréciation de la
livre qui a entraîné une inflation des
prix là bas et donc la perte de pouvoir
d'achat sur de combien vous
consommateurs anglais et donc nous pûmes
anglais lalala pro de production
économique de l'économie britannique est
passée de 0 7% au dernier trimestre 2007
à 0 3% au premier trimestre de 2010 et
et où les économies sont en train de
dire c'est l'effet préc site est ce que
c'est encore une fois ça ne vous
inquiète pas hier ce qui n'est pas un
problème parce que là c'est le même axe
que ya pas de briques site
mais je crois que son s'accroissant cela
au premier trimestre est en dessous de
ce que tout le monde avait prévenu déjà
oui ne vous parle pas de ça je n'avais
d'accord mais pour vous dire avec le
modèle européen tel qu'il est ça marche
ça marche pas mieux qu'avec un pays qui
est en train de sortir l'union
européenne oui mais penser que ce qui
est en cause dans notre
contre-performance et parce qu'on n'a
pas su adapter notre modèle compétitif à
l'économie européenne est ce vous avez
bien connu
on fait oui down on me répondait sur le
bric c'est vraiment un contre exemple là
parce que le bric site pendant que nous
nous avons accumulé du chômage
on fait des emplois voilà les gars mais
le vent tourne
des locaux qui n'étaient pas assez bons
ils ont crié ils ont fait des emplois
voilà donc pour le chômage a régressé
les allemands aussi à karité comment ils
vont sortir vivants sort nos voisins
européens devant soir l'union beau cd de
l'union et vous verrez qu'à ce moment là
la grande bretagne retrouvera sa liberté
notamment de bâtir des accords avaient
beaucoup d'autres pays dans le monde et
vous verrez que le royaume uni aura très
certainement une croissance supérieure à
celle de la france dans les années rire
si nous continuons vous savez que les
grandes banques sont en train de
délocaliser toutes leurs activités ne
vous voit pas vers l'europe elles sont
là et sont donc je ne crois pas à base
d'ail que l'on me rende moins en
permanence voilà j'ai alors on a compris
on va pas vous faire changer d'avis on
est d'accord on n'ira pas et ne croyez
pas un certain nombre de deux fait qu'on
vous rapporte quand même alors on va
parler des législatives non mais je dis
attendez il ya un fait celui-là qui est
bien clair c'est que le magnifique
projet de l'union européenne qui devait
nous apporter l'emploi la croissance et
le bonheur aujourd'hui se révèle être
une catastrophe puisque notre
agriculture et nos industries nos
services sont en extrême souffrance
notre dette n'a jamais été aussi haute
notre commerce extérieur jamais autant
en berne et nous continuons à produire
des déficits alors qu'il veut pas que ce
modèle fonctionne c'est pratique c'est
pratique un bouc émissaire
écoutez il ya des courbes moi je
reprends les étudiants que sa pire il ya
depuis l'introduction de l'euro
on voit bien que les déficits se sont
creusés dans un creuset que la dette
s'est accentuée que le chômage a
progressé et que nous avons eue d'une
croissance très limitée en ont il faut
se poser les questions alors on va
parler des législatives
oui alors alors les législatives bon
vous êtes on vous reproche peut-être un
flou que vous
[Musique]
euros par don et il ya la question des
législatives il ya matin marine le pen a
dit qu'il n'est pas d'accord législatif
avec nicolas dupont aignan au même
moment nicolas dupont aignan a dit un
accord législatif avec marine le pen
alors quelle est la situation intérieure
il ya des discussions et on verra si
elle débouche sur un accord
si le secrétaire générale statutaire qui
est chargé de ces questions là c'est une
affaire de partis politiques du front
national c'est nicolas bay qui est en
train de négocier de discuter de tout ça
il se peut qu'il y en ait pas il se peut
qu'il y en ai je ne suis pas avoir
fouillé deux favorables
moi je trouve que au regard de ce que
monsieur dupont-aignan a amené
aujourd'hui dans ce deuxième tour je
suis pas défavorable à ce qu'il y ait un
accord gouvernemental électorale avec
monsieur dupont aignan alors un nicolas
dupont aignan ne cesse de se réclamer du
gaullisme
il se dit qu listant en permanence mais
vous c'est intéressant bref vous lever
les yeux au ciel louis aliot parce que
vous vous êtes jamais recommandé c'est
général de gaulle si sa marque de
fabrique
mais moi je ne me suis jamais recommandé
pour des raisons historiques personnel
qui touche à une partie de ma famille et
de la famille politique que qui a été
celle qui s'est opposé au général de
gaulle mais dans cette note jerry en
algérie et notamment sur le drame des
harkis
voilà qu orléans qui a redonné
l'association art qui soutiennent
emmanuel macron journée le comité
national de liaison des harkis qui
rassemble 150 présidents d'associations
marguerittes soutient emmanuel macron
qui seriez vous inspire on a eu la honte
à eux
pourquoi content parce que macrom
précisément est allé à alger devant les
bourreaux de leurs pairs dire que la
france avait commis des crimes contre
l'humanité leur abandon eux et en plus
je les connais ils sont venus voir
marine à perpignan et je peux vous dire
qu'à ce moment là c'était parce qu'ils
avaient développé un bon mélange visent
ils disent et même un conte défend les
valeurs républicaines c'est pour ça
qu'on le souterrain importe de ce qu'ils
disent moi je sais très bien que les
harkis le plus souvent vote pour nous et
je défendrai moi ça me soucier de ce que
pensent par ailleurs ce genre
d'association mais c'est pas de sujet
sur le gaullisme
nous avons toujours bien fait la
différence noue entre eux
la résistance le général de gaulle ce
qu'il avait apporté à l'histoire aux
institutions j'ai un spécialiste de la
vème république
et à l'image de la france dans le monde
tout en ayant un gros désaccord sur le
problème de l'algérie et de la
préservation d'algérie française mais
avec des figures qui ont été des
gaullistes de 40 pas des figures des
résistances des vrais ils sont allés
manifester par exemple à l'arc de
triomphe contre les allemands avant que
les communistes les nord-africains
distance en dernier le cordier qui fait
secrétaire de jean moulin auquel
aujourd'hui manuellement - rendu hommage
comme alain griotteray qui a été le
dernier soutienne de marine le pen dans
les élections et qui était un gaulliste
précisément de quarante et un anti
gaulliste de 62 qui a fait un livre
remarquable que je conseille aux gens
qui nous regardent
pourquoi je ne demande pas pardon voilà
alors lui aller où vous allez me
considérez vous les citer l'historien
jean noël jeanneney dans le monde mais
vous me citer un ancien ministre
socialiste
il est historien aussi ministre
socialiste qui s'occupe de la francisque
demi terrain et qui ne s'occupait pas dû
réveiller parle de vous il s'occupe un
peu de vous et bien aujourd'hui dit il
dit il dit que vous vous rendez hommage
à bastien thiry qui tenta d'assassiner
le général de gaulle en 62 vous faire
une confidence alors les i il ya une
stèle qui rend hommage
un certain nombre de soldats qui ont été
fusillés pendant la guerre d'algérie
quelques la fête ce style qui le maire
rudy de perpignan alors voilà cette
mémoire il faut la laisser la mémoire
des morts aux morts à ceux qui le
rendent hommage et notamment à ceux qui
ont combattu pour préserver l'algérie
c'est plus le sujet aujourd'hui
voilà mais pour vous dire que cette
mémoire là elle est étendue à l'ensemble
du spectre notamment au bord de la
méditerranée
parce qu'il y à peu près là des millions
de rapatriés et de harkis qui vivent et
qui sont attachés à cette mémoire ce que
vous considérez que la france a est
coupable à leur égard a commis quelque
chose de fautifs à leur égard les
rapatriés et les harkis
c'est une évidence les abandonner et les
a trahis après l'avoir dit que
leur avoir dit que la france resterait
là bas mais je veux dire là encore il
faut faire la part des choses nous
sommes en 2017
il faut respecter cette mémoire il faut
solder notamment la sphère des harkis
qui est la plus importante
et parce que c'est un problème moral
gravissime qui n'a toujours pas été
réglée ce sont des anciens combattants
français français qu'on a mis à l'écart
à l'époque parce que précisément il
était musulman ne s'est pas de front
national qu'il après ça ils n'appellent
chez les pouvoir d'alors quand marine le
pen s'est exprimée sur le vel d'hiv ce
qui lui a été reprochée elle a dit la
france en tant que telle n'est pas
fautive là vous dites la france entend
célébrer les biens au gouvernement
français je vous ai dit les
gouvernements français
la france elle n'est pas responsable sur
vous nous avez dit c'est une évidence
elle les a abandonnés la france vous est
posée les gouvernements français mais il
faut pas faire et filles évidemment cet
amalgame à la et gouvernement français
est-ce que derrière ça il n'y a pas au
fond fait que vous n'arrivez pas à faire
votre 2 de l'algérie française
non pas qu'il ait fait le deuil qui
allait enfin la pression que nous on va
parvenir à marier dans votre famille
ça vous touche beaucoup ta votre famille
votre mère pense que nous avons une
dette je le redis par rapport aux harkis
qu'il faudra réparer parce que je vous
demande de venir voir au camp de
rivesaltes commencé jal ont été traités
comme ils ont été traités même après
comme ils le sont encore aujourd'hui il
faut réparer voilà parce que c'est une
fracture douloureuse que ces gens-là
souffre énormément et que cette mémoire
sera apaisée le jour où précisément
on aura solder cette affaire des harkis
voilà donc voilà sur le chapitre du
général de gaulle
mais de gaulle à part à part ça il ya
des gaullistes que nourrit tes os au
front national
et il tient à le rappeler parce que
l'autre jour on m'a fait un peu ce
procès là que vous éprouvez de me faire
quel était le numéro deux de la liste de
jean marie le pen aux européennes de
oui c'était le petit fils du général de
gaulle charles
il de gaulle dit dans une prise de
position publique et c'est le petit-fils
aussi d'une général donne quoi
ikki l'entrecours 1 a assez que l'on
salisse l'uniforme de son grand père en
le récupérant qu'on utilise deux univers
qu'on l'aurait vous avez ailleurs vous
êtes adresse à vous est adressé tout à
l'heure oui cher j'en termine avec ça
parce qu'il ya l'aspect mémoire la
résistance etc
et je pense qu'il faut rendre hommage à
évidemment tout ça mais moi j'ai fait ma
thèse de droit public
le président du jury était jean foyer
comme convoyage y reste modèle au
gaullisme qui était le garde des sceaux
de du général de gaulle jean baucou
discussion avec jean foyer et notamment
sur l'évolution de sa propre famille
politique puisqu'il était repères et
notamment sur l'europe et il a écrit
toute une série de livres qui démontrait
pas rapide mais comment le rpr et tout
les pentes que l'on voit aujourd'hui on
travaille la pince et des gaullistes sur
l'europe d'une manière tournoi évidente
et assume et on vous a entendu tout à
l'heure vous adresser aux électeurs de
jean luc mélenchon n'est ce pas lui à
léo que dites vous aux électeurs que je
souscris au patriote d'accord mais alors
vous vous adressez aussi donc aux
électeurs de françois fillon lequel a
déclaré aujourd'hui ce n'est pas parce
que la france est malade il faut se
jeter dans le vide et le vide pour
françois fillon c'est le programme
économique du front national il met en
garde contre un appauvrissement
irrémédiable une division des français à
cause de votre violence idéologique il
met en garde contre l'isolément par
votre hostilité obsessionnel vis-à-vis
de l'europe que répondez-vous à françois
fillon
rien rien lui répondre à leurs questions
suivra ce que parce que voilà ça fait
partie des poncifs qu'à force de répéter
plus personne n'entend monsieur firent
mener un combat dans une adversité faut
bien le dire général
il a réussi à faire 20% ses électeurs
deux minutes après le livre le 20 heures
se sont retrouvés sans candidat est
appelé à voter macro ceux qui ne veulent
pas faire et moi je lui en appel et moi
je les appelle à bien
mesurer ce que représente monsieur macro
à matière d'atteinte à l'histoire la
mémoire l'identité de la france et
notamment son refus de condamner le
soutien que lui apporte le haut iev et
un certain nombre de musulmans radicaux
ce que je trouve assez curieux il faut
bien le dire ce fillon il est dans le
système ses électeurs votent non mais
lui il est temps il a des bruits
ministre de nicolas sarkozy non alors
pourquoi est-ce que marine le pen est
aller plagier le discours d'un
responsable politique et dans ce système
qu'elle ne cesse de dénoncer la borie
marième plage et je n'arrivais à la gym
pour moi j'attendais ou non
oui mais les mots fusent et des dix mots
extraits entier les mots sur sajoo non
mais attendez
ces mots sortent et 12 sont avait été
prononcé dans ces messieurs fillon qu'il
est à vendre et elle attend différent
c'est de la mauvaise foi
mais si le livre de monsieur photo c'est
une phrase de paul marie coûteaux
discours cape rose c'est une phrase une
citation de paul marie coûteaux
d'enseignants être c'est françois fillon
n'est pas du tout si j'ai marqué je vous
dire ça moi ça me paraissait totalement
anodin mais là les récitations de
napoléon une de clément sociaux
nécessité non mais en plus vous tour
n'était pas si tu me diras ça
n'intéresse personne
bah quand même dit vous commencé comme
personne avait questionné a donné en
revanche vous n'avez pas relevé la la
citation de monsieur macrom quand il
parle
le fn parti de l'anti france vous savez
d'où ça vient non non j'ai pas entendu
vous ferez tout me faut le dire aux gens
qu'on le dit d'ailleurs des ligues des
années 30 antimaçonnique et antijuive
voilà où deux parties de l'indifférence
autre question monsieur à lui on a
beaucoup parlé pas campagne de des
emplois présumés fictifs de l'entourage
de monsieur fillon et il y à la sphère
des emplois présumés fictifs des
assistants parlementaires européens du
fn est-ce que vous avez été vous même
auditionné par les juges est ce qui vous
ont nommé ce qui vous en demander non
parce qu'ils se sont interrogés qui se
sont intéressés à l'emploi d'un de vos
collaborateurs
pour l'instant y'a pas une audition non
est ce que madame le pen va va se rendre
devant les juges
le jour où malicieux des législatives jo
ou le ou l'immunité sera levé oui comme
elle l'a fait la dernière fois promet
elle l'a fait la dernière fois après les
élections et les régionales où elle a
d'ailleurs été blanchi après les
accusations fausses louis aliot vous je
crois que vous restez très fidèle à jean
marie le pen un de lui découle votre
engagement politique comment est ce que
vous avez jugé son apparition il ya air
au pied de la statue de jeanne d'arc qui
était franchement crépusculaire et pète
et pathétique écouté puisque vous avez
c'est vous qui c'est vous qui dit qu'il
donnait le ce que j'en pense maintenant
je ne comprends pas qu'un homme qui a eu
cette vie politique si riche qui s'est
battu pour son pays
lui aussi d'ailleurs dans la résistance
et randonnées après qui a pris les armes
pour aller se battre en indochine qui a
démissionné de son mandat pour les se
battre en algérie qui est un patriote
vrai and arrive aujourd'hui à ce voilà à
une situation moi qui me paraît un peu
pathétique et peut-être le mot et
crépusculaire pour l'heure prenez aussi
ce mot là finalement moi je préfère
voilà j'ai le souvenir de jean marie le
pen que j'ai connu n'est pas du tout
celui que je connais depuis 5h accord
vous devez trouver pathétique merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui
merci à tous merci messieurs
à très vite à tous
[Musique]